[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT: So do you know what my
favorite command line tool is?
FEMALE COMPUTER VOICE:
(SINGING) Matt loves tools yeah.
ADDY: No.
What's your favorite
command line tool?
FEMALE COMPUTER
VOICE: That was weird.
ADDY: So we're using the Say
command, which is probably
the best of the commands.
MATT: I do actually
love command line tools.
Like recently, someone pointed
out the delight of Stop Files.
You know GitHub has their
whole dotfiles.github.io,
and it's literally
just a ton of people
and just their dotfile configs.
And it's basically like dotfiles
are the things that just
set up your profile, right?
So on Linux, you have
Bash M OSX, right?
ADDY: Yeah.
MATT: They both use Bash.
And it's basically like
you can put loads of things
that preset Bash to do all sorts
of crazy stuff just for you.
ADDY: Right.
So if you're someone that finds
themselves using the command
line quite a lot, and
you find that there's
a common set of
tools or workflows
that you use every day, it's
a good idea to alias them.
So I use aliases a
lot in my workflow.
MATT: Yeah.
Because I ended up going through
your dotfiles, and there's
some good things in there.
I got massively confused.
ADDY: There's Probably some
terrible things in there
as well.
MATT: They're also not
your original dotfiles.
You stole them
from someone else.
ADDY: No.
I stole them from
Mathias Bynens,
who has probably one of the
best sets of dotfiles ever.
MATT: He does.
There's tons of
good stuff in there.
I just got super confused
and I forgot everything.
And now I'm probably up to the
point where you are as well.
But I love them.
One of the common
things that I like doing
is I have aliases, where
essentially I just C-S-P.
And it literally just goes
to code or sites or projects.
It's just preset directories,
and I just type one letter,
and it's just there.
ADDY: That's kind
of funny because I
find that I use some of
the same letters for stuff,
but it means something
different for me.
So I've got S set
up to do Get Status.
So if I want to find out the
status of my current branch,
I can just type in S.
So something I do
every day is I end up
cloning repos and
opening up in my editor.
So I use a clone command that
lets me just go and fetch
a repo.
I just type in clone repo name.
It'll clone the repo,
check it out, CD into it,
and then open it
up in my editor.
MATT: So will it clone it just
into that editor you're in,
or will it even go to
the point where it's
just straight into projects?
ADDY: It'll create a
new directory for you.
You can tell it what
parent directory
you want it to write to.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: It's kind of useful.
MATT: That's the
one thing that I
must admit I'm finding more
and more that the Get commands,
I'm probably going to go through
a lot of people's and steal
some things, because I'm still
doing a lot of that manually.
It's getting more
and more cumbersome.
But it's insane.
I've just gotten
to the point where
I feel like everyone should
just spend a bit of time
playing with their terminal,
just setting it up.
Because the other thing
I did was set up .sh.
And the main reason I did
that was because of the themes
that everyone has, and
then you've got plug-ins.
The only one I'm aware that
I'm using is GitHub plug-in.
So if I'm in the terminal,
it's GitHub Repo.
It will go, here's the
branch that they're on.
And then it'll put a little star
whether there's change files
or not that it's committing.
ADDY: So .sh is really useful
for visualizing some additional
information in the context
that you're in at the moment,
which is kind of cool.
MATT: Yeah.
ADDY: Speaking of the command
line, I love using iTerm2.
And it's got some
really nice features.
So in addition to having
a really rich ecosystem
of themes-- again, I'm
using Seti UI as my default
theme in the command line now.
It's also got support
for a history feature.
So it'll record all of the
different console information,
commands that you've been
using the last couple of days.
And you can scrub back
and forth through history.
So you can see, well, I
use these four or five
commands every day.
Maybe I should alias them.
MATT: That's pretty cool.
I think I've just gotten
to the point where
I'm just making up as I go
along what I alias and whatnot.
That's quite a nice
way of doing it.
MALE COMPUTER VOICE:
Your face is weird.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE COMPUTER VOICE: You suck.
MALE COMPUTER VOICE: Not
as much as your face.
[MUSIC PLAYING]